we need some reinforcements up here now
they're starting to pull the gates down
the police calls for backup unanswered
angry crowds breaking in
unimpeded a bipartisan congressional
report calls the response
to the january sixth attack on the u.s
capitol
a failure of intelligence preparation
and imagination
a failure it says led to the deaths of
seven
people including three police officers
the intelligence was out there
and we know that now in fact at the time
many of us knew that
you all were reporting that there was
you know online chatter about violence
connected with that gathering so to me
it was just amazing that that
intelligence did not get in the right
hands here
the report says because no one shared
the intelligence
capitol police and national guard units
weren't equipped and ready to head off
any violent protests
we will never give up we will never
concede
and once the crowds left a rally at the
white house for the capital
the report says the breach and the
violence were inevitable
but this report does not analyze why the
protest happened at all
which is why most senators say they want
an independent
9 11 style commission there are a lot of
other
questions that need to be asked in terms
of why did this occur what motivated
folks to
descend on the capitol to engage in what
was
an insurrection those are questions that
need to be
asked and answered and the commission
would be able to take a more fulsome
look at that the chances of that
happening are diminishing
mainly because of partisan infighting
democrats accuse republicans of trying
to protect
former president donald trump and his
administration
while republicans say democrats are
playing politics of their own
one of my big problems with the january
6th commission is it was
outlined the members the commissioners
and the staff is going to be appointed
by
congressional leadership so again
how do you get to the bottom of
potentially what congressional
leadership knew and when they didn't
know it
the report calls for more intelligence
sharing and more training exercises
and improved oversight but it can't
address the bigger issue
why did people who call themselves
patriots try to overthrow their
government on january 6th
rosalyn jordan al jazeera washington